okay so this is a wizard battle just
tell me you wash that shirt nope okay I
just let it collect and collect and
collect like your funk and smell because
what I'm gonna do is sell it on eBay
that is revolting but you'll probably
get a lot of money there if somebody
make a gif of that where where I have
one of his dancing bought like right
here dancing and like the family going
yeah you going
so yeah there'll be the new one just
keep going like that it it won't be as
good cuz doesn't have as much Jason
why but that's a boy trying to be like
okay this is a wizard battle um so this
I saw that title I'm like yeah excited
for that and it's it's good and I love
the setup that the setup is that Finn
and Jake are in this they're in this
arena where there's gonna be this big
wizard battle which is probably the
saddest thing cuz it's this big again
just adding more to like sort of the
apocalypse then cuz there's like it's
all empty except for like a few teddy
bears as they uh-oh that was some kids
great you know because more more
depressing you realize what those likely
happen um we're watching a concert yang
bomb goes off all the teddy bear that's
how the teddy bear survived it you know
what I guess we'll talk about poverty
duck-and-cover smart teddy bear who
would have known that better or turn so
you got there in this stadium there's
all these wizards coming in they're
gonna do a wizard battle and the Ice
King is in there and he's gonna cheek as
you can use a weapon you can use weapons
and the winner gets a kiss from Princess
Bubblegum which seems really not fair
seeing how there's like clearly women
Wizards to with I mean if they could be
lesbos who knows but at the same time
it's like that's really not fair
one of your three woman in here they
would live to leave and what did he say
said no one leaves but that means they
also know when they get your two cats so
yeah and then there's one wizard who is
like doesn't want to kiss her like
angrily does not want to kiss her and
what was the guinea was like turn and
push how can I forget that male is a
great name um and and fing goes in
disguised as a wizard to protect
people's lips from ice King's lips just
not really that big a sacrifice really I
mean is that like that speaketh die hard
thing to fight for but he makes a deal I
disagree completely well they're not
going out which it doesn't matter what I
want anyone to kiss you know my you know
even before we were together
yeah but were you I would fight for
those lips even if you weren't dating at
that point yeah especially from some
feeble crusty white man but that's like
stalker ish you ask the person before he
has no claim owner sharing partnership
with her so but you can still fight to
keep them away from it i but if he won
okay he didn't win fair and square as
the cheater his way showed that that's
basically what he did named okay Mike he
wants the kids to also which is this I'm
sorry this relationship still seems kind
of stupid because I'm not saying even
about like the Marceline thing I'm
talking about she grows up and she's
like oh I'm just pushing you away now
it's like I don't get that it's I I
think I have explained it I don't know
but anyway okay so we'll get to in a
second so they have this wizard battle
which is kind of cool when you see it
and there's a lot of dandy things going
on a lot of old wizards return yeah some
of those we saw but was that green one
the forest wizard horses yeah the naked
what I'm thinking
yeah so the Frog I didn't even see
though he was there so odds cool some
characters Tom it was cool but yet you
did see them kind of fight but for the
most part is focusing on like the Ice
King
cheating and
getting in so I kept the deal with the
other wizard and in the end uh they kind
of win and with the power freak yes the
power shriek which is like the most
controversial of magic spells it's the
most pathetic
I get all I said what he said the most
but that I wasn't pathetic but it was
the most what was it it was like yeah I
think it was pathetic
it's like hitting a guy to the crotch or
some yeah yes you know yeah you'd win
right away but yeah so this is so he
wins a maze reveal that he was you know
the wizard the whole time he's not a
wizard so he gets the kiss that then
also slap which is pretty funny and it
kind of just ends there and I was kind
of hoping for like you know cuz this
grand wizard the Maurice LaMarche cat
thing whatever that was you know it
seems to like to turn people in the cats
very randomly and yeah I sir thought
like when he was revealed to be a
cheater as I okay everyone meet up next
year is I felt like it was gonna lead to
like a big climax our door punished and
he was gonna like zap him and do all
this there'd be like a big thing but no
but just sort of rugged that's it then
don't forget Ice King in his glasses
yeah that's the glue that brought
everything yeah yeah that's in his dirt
glasses okay what are the dirt glasses
wait to look people comment and maybe
we'll actually see if anyone knows okay
yeah I saw you bring that up to Bri
which is good for me yes make it fast
boy waiting don't worry go on okay I
won't worry and go on uh so it was
alright I was really hoping for it's
looking for something called friggin
wizard battle I was really hoping for
something wow I can barely see it's
actually from the show and they just
haven't won no this is these are dirt
glasses so on a scale from one to ten
oh I'm stuck oh okay hey they never had
much better don't even cover your in my
SIOC go on is the neck me look SIOC but
I'm so so like when the wizards we're
battling like that was kind of fun but
it's like man i real
wanted to see more of it this is one of
those episodes where literally you could
just do the setup to show the Wizards
fighting and then just stop and I'd be
totally satisfied but you only get like
a little bit and I know maybe a story
and everything but it wasn't even like
that much of a story it's another like
Oh fake kiss but she's still kind of a
bitch towards him so whatever and it's
like I don't know it's like wizard
battle where's her battle they can be
huge and it's like and the idea is cool
I don't know I felt them take full
advantage of what you could do with that
setup or at least didn't focus on the
right part that you can take full
advantage of speak you see I'm dirt
glasses turn you into a cat no it's like
all the cats in the episode and why is
noticing this yes there there are cats
oh yeah that's right no actually there's
one thing that did remind me of though
is that I mean it's always true in these
episodes but like I noticed even more in
this one like yeah why is he noticing
this eh he's playing with the cat the
cat at first it's like this little thing
walking around on his crown and such a
little detail and I was even a scene
where like when they're about to start
like Bubblegum's up there so you get a
kiss from Princess Bubblegum she yeah
she's going like this which is really
funny but then like when it backs off
like maybe a minute or two later you see
the blip and she's still doing it and
let me say in animation I mean you you
kind of have to be told to do that you
can't just be like I'll be funny but
just improvises know you a lot of times
you have to sort of run it by people and
so because it's not like just a little
improv you have to draw every frame and
it's like no we didn't want that that's
a lot of money wasted so I'm wondering
how much of it like the director looks
and says yes put this in this is these
are really important details or if
animators come up and be like hey I just
thought in this shot would we need this
going on and the director jo soares yeah
sure that's a great idea
they'd be my guess the second option
that happens a lot cos dude that's
there's so many little details like that
like I said just a little cat on the
helmet and just her still doing that on
the screen and stuff I mean it's like
those details really add up and I
it's part of the charm of the show yes
your turn
no I liked it it was fun I just find it
I just find it funny going back a few
episodes to thin ones are for wimps
well done this episode is all about the
wizard battle it kind of depends on what
Moody's and either he's kind of thinks
Wizards are pathetic or he wants to be a
wizard really bad well I think I'm up
and down like a kid yeah I was gonna say
it's very much like a kid and I think
there's a lot of times where people try
to use the kid argument like well
they're a kid it's just an excuse and
there is a mindset to kids you know
there is a way that it's not totally
sporadic it's it is emotional it does
change but it's kind of what benefits
them at the moment mixed with what their
background and their environment is like
being a parent we realize that mean you
being a parent I realize exactly how up
and down a child can be with tastes and
interests well I love this I'm done with
that I love this I'm done with that my
folks would tell you the same thing I I
guess I had like a new fair like every
week except for Turtles that lasted like
a friggin eternity and the only other
thing I can think of before I finally
say okay is the abracadaniel I like the
way they show how like he struggles with
his magic I just thought was a very
creative way of doing it I don't know
can most of time it's usually just like
a wizard or fairy something like
pointing or witches and they can't like
quite get and they just go park or
something can kind of be there and then
disappears and I just really like you
could sort of really feel it stretching
well I like him the guy did of the
meteor attack and every kid annuals look
abracadaniel and the Ringo comes out and
does nothing then you get to crush to
use like my buddy squishy I thought
maybe that was gonna come back I knew
the baby is squishy but just I can
survive that so I don't liked it I it
was okay I I just her
the title and for the setup I sort of
thought there'd be a lot more but yeah
is what it is and and meow that's really
all you can say
don't drop the Derka Derka a man in a
Jake shirt wearing their glasses
meowing saying don't drop the turkey
dirt that's all I can say about Pam well
aren't you gonna tell them a little
something about the next episode since
you know what it is and everyone's all
like okay yeah so this is one of you
like a segue this time okay I'll do the
same way because it's the only episode
I've never seen it but I know what it is
and everyone goes nuts about it and
they've already been talking about like
it's Kobe God and that's Fionna and cake
and I know I don't know if there's gonna
be like a segue from this episode or not
but I just know it's one where like
Finn's a girl
I think Jake's a girl I know he's
definitely a cat and like all the roles
are reversed gender wise at least I know
there's guys I've seen like a million of
these cosplays which you kind of see
anyway you've seen people switch it
around I'm just saying like oh that's
just a cross play or whatever that's
just a cross play and they're like no no
there's an episode there's an episode
and I'm almost wondering because these
people clearly must have gone to
conventions or know about conventions is
that they did that intentionally you
know they're sort of set this up so that
you know girls can dress as Finn and
then vice versa or if they maybe saw it
at a convention center the origin of
this episode I would be curious of and I
haven't even seen the episode yet
that's how built up it is yeah he's
gonna hate it
probably